day three of hashtag mug Club quarantine
where everything is free in front of the
paywall what's usually available
exclusively for mug clubbers and we've
added three more shows per week Monday
Wednesday Friday good morning mug club
we just ask that you tune in leave a
like comment and join monk with if you
can we're offering a promo code
quarantine at loud OHS credit.com slash
mug club you get $30 off that's the
highest discount or low it's the most
money discount that we've done since the
Vox ad pocalypse and I'll tell you what
I'm at this prime say well what am i
what am i doing at two shows a day I
might not make it but I'm going to do my
best so enjoy the show you'll notice
that it's it's a it's a it's it's it's a
show um I got water all over myself
alright let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to town para espanol or emailed
us thank you for contacting us
my name is how can I help you today oh
okay thank thank the Lord you've
answered I would like to file a
complaint - I should ask I'm sorry how
are you today I'm wonderful how are you
doing I have been better like like I
said I would like to lodge a complaint
if you please
yeah are you the representative I would
speak with because I want to talk with
someone who can make a change over there
at Dove I don't want it to just go to
some you know folks who just send it on
to the higher-ups um I don't have the
authority to give you any one hires but
I can absolutely take note of your
comment and it does get passed along
that is sort of the chain of commands
here okay well I am calling regarding
your real beauty campaign you wear your
real beauty campaign about body
positivity yeah and I really appreciate
that okay I'm gonna let you I don't want
to say at first I appreciate y'all doing
that work I appreciate that you want to
represent people with different people
non non-binary x' okay non-binary then
and women and and people from different
cultures different races different body
types because i did it that's hard right
but I still I do not I myself am NOT
represented at all by this campaign and
I am frankly offended that people of my
ilk have been left out I'm just sorry to
hear that to confirm your calling
because the real beauty campaign you
still feel excluded from absolutely let
me tell y'all I am a real beauty I'm
saying I think y'all have a blind spot
because I am a non a gender
non-conforming person of color you see
that in the campaign no no you don't you
don't see that in the campaign and that
guess what is that does that mean I'm
not a real
you do know and yeah a gender
non-conforming person of color
okz of color and and I'm a quasi amputee
I don't say that my campaign is that 'no
campaign you got any quasi quasi
amputees in the campaign no no how about
folks with rickets I also have rickets I
have four rickets so let me tell you let
me tell you my name is my name is Jesse
okay Jess ' I'm telling you what I see
when I see that campaign is we want
people of all body types - it does as
long as people out there part of a
demographic they're gonna buy a soap but
there's enough people right we got we
got skinny people we got fat people we
got black people we got lesbians right
we got gays but we don't have a
combination of a non-conforming person
of color quasi amputee with rickets I
apologize for that
you do feel excluded by that and I can
absolutely empathize
I know you apologizing and listen I know
I know you get people to just be pissed
off calling the other time so I don't
want to come down on you I don't wanna
come down y'all right because I
understand like it's not your fault but
that's what I want to talk to somebody
who can make a change because I know you
got to apologize but yo I wanna ask you
how you how do you feel how do you feel
when you hear that do you think do you
feel good about that that I'm not
representing that campaign you know I
can definitely empathize with emphasized
on some place obviously I've never been
any issue so that is not something that
I could feel but I am sorry and I can't
imagine oh I'm sorry
it feels you know what it feels like it
feels like I live in death it feels like
I'm alive but I'm dead at the same time
because it's like I might as well be
dead because they nobody recognizing my
existence and I don't know why you know
listen you get Pat's on the back from
other white people up there Williamsburg
pushing black folk out and they talking
about how they'll progressive issue and
then you got someone like me how do I
listen I am a I am a non-conforming
person of color
we already listen you can cross you
cross that off the list
we don't even get to cross an apt in
rickets let alone single income
household I'm a single mom right now I
don't see that in there yes I don't see
y'all have interviews with your models
let me look into that for you
I can already answer the question it's
not your fault but nope nope we talking
about all different kinds of beauty I'm
just supposed to look at me like oh
that's a that's a that's a fat white
[ __ ] I'm supposed to think that purse
is good luck but I don't know nothing
about I want to hear what that black
woman there that black woman I want to
hear what she has to say
I won't hear what she has to say why she
use and of what made her want to do the
campaign for Doug you telling me oh
everybody's beautiful but we all
supposed to have self-confidence and
it's all well and good but I'm just
supposed to look at their bodies and
their bodies they ain't represented you
know I represent about me body is that a
white and black but they all people they
ain't got no they ain't got no gender
non-conforming people of color
they all got legs or - what can y'all do
about this who do I gotta talk to to
make a change cuz I get it y'all
progressives but it seems like y'all
progressive in a way that's maybe
comfortable and what I'm doing right now
I hope you understand what I'm doing I'm
just trying to make sure that you are
all little and not you cuz it sounds to
me like you you cooled it sounds to me
like you understand where I'm coming
from but I want to make dove just a
little bit uncomfortable so y'all can
feel the pain that I feel every day as a
gender non-conforming person of color
who is a quasi amputee with rickets in a
single income household what we got to
do what I can do is forward your
comments to the brand if you'd like I
can take down their contact information
in case they're inclined for contacting
you sorry I'm trying to type as I talk
but is that a joke about my closet NBA
because you I know you didn't just make
a joke about the fact that I can't type
at all I was no that's not all I say
only apologize I was being genuine and
that I was
apology accepted but don't let me catch
you doing again people do you know in
your life this is what happens a lot
people you know you know how we destroy
racism in this country you know how we
got past racism do you know
well it's people who thought they
thought black people were were worse
they thought black people who are
animals are left and right and then all
of a sudden they hung out would black be
whatever less hey think I'm so bad
people need to know people of other
stripes and other patterns so that they
can then know that we all want that we
are all the world right that's what you
get exposed to people and then you no
longer scatter them right how many
people there dove no people like me
people who are gender non-conforming
folks of color quasi amputees of rickets
how many people do you know like me how
many people to just supervisor know like
me I can definitely see you fight and
not in that it is not something I can't
say that I know someone who is a quasi
amputee with records you say I use its
when you say that that's like you saying
that I don't exist I'm very empathetic
with and it would be more happy to you
know get your contact information passed
was rolling to the brand whose name I
gotta speak with the supervisor cuz I
appreciate that you empathize but I want
to make sure the people there who making
decisions who's going out and putting
this putting this up there and
cosmopolitan in a land that they hear
from me literally so you do want to
speak as a supervisor
yeah if that's gonna make a change I'm
just calling trying to make a change we
are to change we see if you don't mind
I'm gonna say Shawna Bruce hold when I
reach out to my supervisor and see who's
available City Hall
[Applause]
and I know they didn't just take hoedown
music up in his mouth I'm about to lose
my good afternoon thank you for calling
death my name is one of the supervisors
is this Jesse hi this is Jesse alright
Jesse I understand you were calling in
today regarding the the real beauty
campaign yes can I say ma'am yes ma'am
yeah yes ma'am I mean I spoke and I
spoke with and I gotta tell you it was
great it was very helpful
okay I know that y'all deal with people
on customer service all the time calling
in pissed I get it's not your fault but
it is really hard as a gender
non-conforming person of color quasi
amputee with rickets to find somebody to
talk to that will listen to me speak my
truth okay well I certainly understand
this is in regards to the campaign that
you saw and and where did you see that
advertisement see that advertisement
that's the problem it's like you know
what else you know one of those
paintings that has like the eyes that a
little bit further back than the rest of
the painting so when you move the eyes
are following you it's like that
everywhere I go it's on YouTube I go to
buy some clothes it's showing up in my
Auto ads I see I saw it on the subway I
see the real beauty ads anyway here's
the thing here's the thing okay
I appreciate the concept I did the idea
of a real of real beauty is great you
got people of all different shapes and
sizes that's fantastic I don't see I
look at all of them women and people and
not but I don't see my face I don't see
myself ever do it at all and I want to
know what does thanks then it's okay to
exclude people of my ilk
if y'all real gonna campaign when I am I
don't know don't let out nobody tell you
different I am a real beauty well I
certainly don't disagree at all believes
that all women and girls have the right
to sue anybody actually
say woman agenda median culture right
that's right not a woman or gender
non-conforming but I understand y'all
still making baby steps I'm not looking
to play gotcha hanging on anything but
then why is someone like myself not
represented let me ask you this when you
look at that campaign if you can bring
it up right now what do you see what
kind of people do you see no I certainly
understand and I'm so sorry that you may
not have been represented what you think
it's a me I'm telling you that it's
proactive I'm telling you listen it's
not just dumb it's everybody I don't see
anything anytime I go and see a
commercial I got a I got a water burger
I go down to Carl's jr. Burger King I
don't see nobody like man anything
campaigns and then I hear Doug doing a
real beauty campaign it's gonna be
including people of all different shapes
and sizes a racist I'm starting to think
things are looking up for Jesse and then
I do it it's the same stuff it's the
same that I see what's every other
campaign that's why I'm most upset about
this because I'm talking about I'm
looking I'm a small business owner it's
what we call opportunity cost
opportunity cost because this was a this
was a mama for someone like me to shine
and we ain't even included and I
absolutely did I just hear somebody
laughing on that hole you have my ass on
speaker no there was not I'm sorry
around me but I'm sorry now there's
nothing funny about this because I live
in this every day it's not down some
more detergent okay I live every day as
a gender non-conforming person of color
cause I am 50 with rickets single income
household I'm a single mother and here's
something else I was asking I was asking
I want to know about these people I
don't want you to see their bodies it's
like go of saying hey hey hey everybody
motive their bodies
we're looking into Beauty do you have
any interviews with their people what
are your lights where their hobbies are
they remember of the Rotary Club what do
they do I have no idea I'm just
and a bunch of white bodies and since
black women and dove calls that progress
is that what you think is progress
you think that's inclusive no I
understand your concern absolutely and I
appreciate your comments and I'm
absolutely going to forward those to the
brand FA okay I appreciate so what what
do you expect what do you propose we do
about it for the brand
listen you call night I call Gillette I
call brie Larson in the Marvel comments
and all that I've been making calls
everyone always says little forwarded
someone else ain't nothing change we are
the change we see I understand
completely and I assure you I will pass
your information and your feedback on to
the branch so that they're made aware of
your concerns that's all we got
I'm answering this how do you you how do
you identify sound like you got a lovely
voice it sounds like you're a woman
correct yes
and if I'm asked have you always been a
woman I have so you don't have a clue
what kind of pain someone like me goes
through every day having to deal
afterwards with happy having effectively
myself mutilated and then sutured up and
they give me that they give me a device
that I got to use to reopen that wound
every day just so I can go around living
like you and you know how much harder
that is when you got rickets it's not an
easy procedure so I want to know who do
you have do you another one of your
department who might be able to share my
pain who might be able to relate with my
struggle do you have anybody in your
department who is gender non-conforming
gargle wickets I know I I do not under
any wicket see Avnet office that's
information that I don't have I
apologize you can tell is the eyeball
test it's just the eyeball test it ain't
that hard to figure out you would know
if you've seen someone with rickets
you've seen somebody walking around like
like Doc Holliday like he'd go on out
west for tuberculosis
well I'm very sorry Jesse I'm not
familiar with it so I don't know much
about it do you know what I I do not but
that doesn't mean I don't care about the
situation send that up and I want to see
in that next campaign from Doug I want
to see from Dove someone like me
Matt called me I am available Jeff ' II
you can call me back you got a you got a
pencil there you got a pen you can write
with I can absolutely take down your
information here let's do this that I'm
sorry so that's JD is apostrophe II yes
sometimes I use a semicolon okay okay
and you can call me back and let stuff
cut out there you're almost up okay Qi
don't you get another notice another pen
for yourself that you can write with
with you're functioning in Han oh sorry
is there a last name that I can apply to
this as well nope it is just Jeff ' II I
went through a lot of work to get that
my driver's license I don't need a last
name
all right not a problem at all all right
I'll absolutely forward this information
along you go ahead and you do that you
tell them but just a possibly is
available and not only not only for
Beauty shots but I'm available for an
interview to speak to the transgender
gender non-conforming people of color
quaza amputee with rickets single mother
community at large
a lot of us out there now all right
absolutely I can do that for you all
right I appreciate it and see people add
of maybe you think we fighting I think
we're finally talking I'll talk to you
later
I'm waiting for that call well thank you
so much for your time today Jesse and
you have
I'm here laughing right now on your
voice so Jesse what note we had a good
phone call now I gotta ruin it by
sitting there laughing laughing like a
cyst like a cyst woman and by the way I
think I can hear from your voice that
you a white sis woman laughing and a
woman of color gender non-conforming
quasi fut sale income household wealth
rickets and not at all just me I was so
sorry if you took it that way I
certainly did not mean anything at all
I'm actually kind of confused a little
bit so I'm just apologize for any
confusion what confusion because I I
just apologize because I was not
laughing at you in any any way and I'm
so sorry if you thought that yeah I did
think that it sounded like it
it sounded like it no no I'm very very
sorry that you you may have assumed that
I'd not have I don't know if maybe you
may have heard somebody in the
background having a conversation with
someone else but I just Jackson as well
make sure that you don't find my
condition funny and that you're taking
it seriously and it's gonna go in some
suggesting box with a bunch of other
angry white women saying ah 77 cents on
the dollar and I wanted to go to someone
who really understands the community
that I represent gender non-conforming
people of color quasi amputees single
income household with rickets no I
absolutely do understand in our black
people really like you know Jesus was
black did you know that's enough it's
bad enough but I got a look at posters
and paintings all over the place with
Jesus looking like he just came out of a
an SS catalog and blonde hair and blue
eyes Jesus was black
oh I like to go back to data alright
Jeff you thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay and now we're here doing the Ash
Wednesday just me quarterblack Gerald
and with audio Wade and hey Gerald
that's a that is a good color on you is
what I would feel compelled to say if it
weren't the only color that you wear
it's true it's true I do our other
colors are so maybe you're more colored
we're the ones that your wife clears
yeah that's the white that a safe thing
to do that's the it is the it is the
background to the Indian going at night
that's the other color you wear Indian
what I didn't even know what that means
wow so lost right never study history
it's like Gerald unless it happen in his
lifetime he didn't exist other than I'm
a history buff but yeah and you're not
the Indian Native American what in
television went out sat on the day it
was interesting remember oh well you
just act like you didn't know I knew it
in that context but you just said the
Indian going out on a Micah what huh I
wasn't 70 years old you just watching TV
until it went out on drugs again a
little bit give me some skin
I'm your host of course I look like a
hopless butthole today I should say is
there a hopeful butthole listen to hobos
but oh gosh Gary way off I think said a
hopeless but yeah it's interesting sure
they're gonna be hopeful but holds I
don't know before the big show
yeah before the strange okay physical
and I wasn't having we had to pre-tape
smash Wednesday's because I'm not
allowed to have any drag go and they
said they said cigars are fine I said I
smoke cigars you know like we do it
every time on the show so don't you deny
a claim because imagine that if I go I'm
like I would like to claim on my wife
would say I'd like to claim my life
insurance over my cold corpse say sorry
you can't claim it your husband was a
smoker she goes what no he wasn't they
just go close Wednesday plays on a loop
like a morphine drip
yeah no we were just talking about the
sir I said before we went on air war it
went on air before we I got two hours
sleep and I'll get back to my insurance
physical I said heroin is child's play
compared to fentanyl and
Audio weighed God love him he goes like
I wouldn't use a word child's play for
heroin okay let me be clear if you take
a syringe full of heroin and you've been
doing it your entire life if you were a
heroin baby and you've never stopped
heroin and you put a grain of fentanyl
in there you die immediately that's how
strong is child's play
exactly a grain but it's like the size
of a grain of rice like you kill you
with fentanyl and these things thing or
is it just a guess you overdose so in
that way Michael Jackson was doing
though seriously he was doing everything
no but there was one particular thing
that he was given as a sleeping I don't
remember what it was six-year-old well
taking so I went in for my physical
didn't really start the cigar um like
yeah why did they pump me up yeah I had
to do a physical and they said oh no
occasional cigars our finest no that's
fine I said yeah just make sure there's
no nicotine in your system as well would
I have it from a cigar yeah we think so
Mike well then are they fine fine but
don't have any don't die and have
Mickeys I said okay so I went a long
while without there's a smoking any
cigars or anything like that yeah and by
the way they used to tell you that
nicotine is addictive as heroin when
you're a kid I was like I kind of would
have liked to have a cigar yeah I don't
know if it's comparable heroin addicts
out there let me know and and then I
went and I found out that I use this CBD
and I think we're having a CBD sponsor
actually come onto the show and turns
out that I am immediately put into the
tobacco user category anyway because
it's full spectrum even if it's 0.3
percent THC they filed me as a
recreational drug user so that goes from
six thousand dollars a year to
thirty-four thousand a year for the plan
light you can test again in 12 months
thanks are you serious this is what's
broken with our American medical system
I called ahead I said do I need it fast
because I have to do this blood work and
they said no you don't need going like
someone's the last time you ate I said
seven o'clock which was giving me 12
hours now and then the doctor didn't
appreciate how fit I was oh yeah yeah
where do the recovery
the hard test done these things so your
heart rate over a hundred that's it and
I'm basically a [ __ ] right now my me
both wrists shoulder somebody I can't
really do I can't really do any jumps I
wanted me to do squat thrusts I just do
this I'll just you like some light kind
of shadow box I got my heart rate to 142
right and then after one minute they
test it it was 72 or 73 there you go
she's like I think that's pretty good
I'm like that's fantastic so the whole
category and they said then their
computers were down today in this asana
he's gonna take a little while and I
said and I was knocking the appointment
was at 7:00 in the morning
yeah 7:15 so I assume they open at 7:00
sorry right like I can see her in the
window and I'm knocking it says oh she's
not answering ring the doorbell Mike
well I don't want to assume she's yeah
so I ring the doorbell she looks and
goes back and then at 7:20 another lady
who I had never seen before I couldn't
see through the vestibule comes out and
I was out there I was knocking sticking
yeah we don't open till 7:15 like first
off you could let me in second at 7:20
yeah as you're unlocking and turning on
the light you know that how you guys
were was early and I think the physical
that that could have taken half an hour
took an hour and 45 minutes at least Wow
and I still have all the blood she
spilled blood in my arm she spilled it
on my arm that my elbow is stained with
my own blood so life insurance is this
what you're talking about or how I'm
trying to take you out basically you
guys are covered if I die everyone here
gets paid for a good long while but I
think it's actually harder for you to
cover but we have to put out it do we
have to still do a show I know you get
paid for nothing that's fantastic that's
very close to what happens now I don't
get to do that I hope you had a hell of
a trip to Disney World too cute Maddy no
seriously I'm most wonderful place on
the planet I just hope that you enjoy it
because yeah I live vicariously through
you
what is the pairing of the week of the
week is Olivia
and miquelon 12 I can't read it so
cheerio cheerio Cask guys foolish
because Oliver is a brand it's not a
cigar and that's why doesn't have a
picture and there are also so many
different subsidiaries it's also like
the most common name over there
Nicaragua just picking like I'll be like
saying Smith you're my best buddy is a
gut mr. Smith who which mr. Smith John
yes Jacob Jingleheimer is my name to
anyone but I appreciate any also I it's
not lost on me that you picked the rice
Wonsan did you just hit them I did yeah
give me some all right so we have some
but you guys are sending in your video
questions at adhikam slash ask I was
arguing with audio wait earlier before
the show because he's a joking he was we
were talking about the war effort versus
New Deal and what pull us out of the the
Great Depression and we actually both
agree he just he likes to he likes to he
likes to praise Hitler it's very weird
audio Wade wrote he came in I'm like
wait you came in from you worked at it
you what did you work the first ministry
I'm like this make sure you cosign it
yeah but I will say you have been a
great surprise and Gerald you are my
professional life's biggest
disappointment yeah I think I think Wade
is here to balance me out how we will
but this is Moneyball right what this is
like Moneyball you have to have like a
really great audio person now to balance
me out yeah you know Moneyball like that
I don't want to here's the thing I don't
want to say like I'm really good audio
person well you didn't you never did
audio no I'm just you the TriCaster
goodness half the time you forget to
turn off the fade you pick up the
TriCaster really quick that's a tough
deal yeah we were back watching the
jihadi Bond intro yeah and it just had
props by good because that was before I
actually knew black yeah
it's not people think it's a joke when
we used to ask you like what is that in
Spanish look why do you what the yeah
why do you keep asking like you're
Mexican you did that I will say I've
never seen anybody put together props
and it's the kind of thing you could
lock me in a cell and I can't get out
until I can make an r2d2 like you did
out of uh you know a paperclip some yarn
and a trash can yeah I never get out day
yeah done it's like The Count of Monte
Cristo without a third act I just end in
the cell yeah materials I don't I will
say this now I do feel like I'm pretty
consistent with praise with people but I
don't give any praise if it's not
warranted so for example I'm never gonna
tell you that you run fast let's do this
let's well maybe some questions we'll go
can we pick the order can we play the
question of how Gerald and I met yes
okay well let's not do that right now
here's one thing I will say it does
impress me to about Garrett his swimming
ability ha ha so can someone else I'm
very very tired today and this is just
you this is why we have the payroll talk
Jay Leno like you so you're like the
MacGyver of prop make a little bit you
can just make it was the reference yeah
really
yeah that's what I'm sayin Steven if you
could say one nice thing about Garrett
what would you what would you say well
no I just said they did great
I'm just trying to help but I remember
too we did I don't know it was it was
the first Crowder confronts the one we
redid to open minds of America at that
Democratic convention yes it was that
was a service because again Kuhn right
at this point quarterblack Garrett was a
he was Garrett I'm history he was what
they would say like a featured player in
SNL but he really wasn't doing as much
as he is now right and we were there and
they got kind of dicey where some people
got physical and at that point I just
have my head in the swivel I'm going
okay where are people who can possibly
hurt me I can't necessarily be aware of
everyone on the team right I went back
it went back and watched the footage I
noticed some people without it who like
shrunk back and basically left a wide
opening the people just tee off on him
and I see Garrett like a little John
Belushi like you think all right you
like looking for it all right all right
throw down he was ready to throw fists
nice he's a little overeager but I can
yeah so I appreciated thank you and know
and I will say everyone I mean audio
weight obviously is great with the audio
and then very very funny that was area
total I found out that he was planning
it all along to write for the show and
anything was my idea
inception that's good I'm very sneaky
he's very sneaky thought and then
Jarrell ups we've been friends for a
long time you're out you're very sharp
you have a great voice for radio to back
woman radio you saved her ass because I
was still not a project and boys to come
in like as a guest and have them just
come in with some points yeah very sharp
guy very sharp guy who occasionally
meaning always steps on jokes but that
was my thing for a while like it's so
many times it was my stick but we're
just rags in dental just like by the way
bill yeah only the people he likes like
it on the phone with me and he's lucid I
will apologize
well okay Steven what's the solution I'm
like I don't know this is the exact
conversation I don't know I thought I
kind of paid you X because you could
figure out what was wrong he told me
about that by the way anyone can say no
no is a great lawyer who finds out how
to say yes I mean there's some through
everything with it there's everyone here
I'm really really blessed to have the
team really honest like I'm so grateful
there's no one here who I dislike yeah
there really isn't there's no one here
who and out of all I'm closer than that
one girl
what do you mean know there have been
people there's no one here right no no
no so that brings us to let's uh the
conversation was how yeah here we go hey
gang it's Natalie
I was wondering how did you guys how did
you meet up with Gerald it's always
something that's actually been on my
mind since we know like Garrett and
Maddie and a couple other people
ticket but as somebody who was from
Detroit and French Canada like how did
you guys like how did that friendship
start or how did you guys first meet and
stuff like that it's something I think
you've ever talked about um well thank
you very much Ashley was it Ashley
Natalie Natalie Natalie so the question
was it Natalie or Ashley
just don't go sailing with Robert Wagner
like an old Natalie Wood reference with
Gerald as far as Gerald is like that
doesn't exist because I wasn't alive for
it I don't think that's it you still
look at how Chad were when I do this
with Gerald look Laurie to go yeah
here's no there okay no life don't even
get me started on quantum physics which
by the way is also a lot of it's just
religion yeah for every way the world
could be there is a world which is that
when I was in humanities and college I
drove my professor nuts I think that's
the reason it's the only time I've ever
gotten a hundred percent of any
assignment was a review of 12 monkeys
because he just wanted me to die yes and
go away Stephen it's the multiverse
multi it's not how did Gerald that's the
question I was at it was a there was a
girl who he liked not at all in fact
okay for like a decade yes
we've talked about that for the birthday
party and people were more my age but
she always hanging out for it you know
listen this respectful I don't mean this
in a you were older than everyone else
there I was an elder in the ministry
that was associated with these people
yes right so I was about 11 I was 7
years older than people I think like 7
or 8 years older you were you were you
stood out yes it's that way because we
were sitting there yes and or because of
comments like this we think it's like a
grace I I know kind of my height
no because you're weird and creepy
though voice
no but you sat there and you were very
nice and you were older and that you
were kind of at the end and I was kind
of at the end was mostly women I
remember yeah and I will sis I've always
been drawn to misfits and not that
you're a misfit in general but even in
that guru you and I were certainly
misfit yes of course and so I just
started talking with Jill and then when
I was driving home with the girl who was
our kind of mutual friend I said who's
that guy said he seems like he seems
like a cool kid I'm uh you know maybe
I'll hang out with him and just after
that I think I actually got our info
your info from her yeah and that was it
we just it just burned a friendship and
we're very different
but I've always I will say I've always
had a heart for misfits probably because
I've always been one I mean I think
everyone here is a little bit odd or at
least different Manny he's a Colombian
from San Francisco and he's a concern
like he's a die-hard and then you
obviously came in and and the reason I
like most we connected and when you came
like you you know you weren't ready to
edit we just needed an editor and we're
let's see if we can bring him back in
part time um
audio wait I know he's probably the most
polished person we've had not really
even want to use to go to college
Republicans there was an event in them
at Cal Poly there was a kid I remember
who had like at it I met I was at Iron
Maiden her Megadeth one of those yeah
that sure time long hair and all these
are the people looked like you know
Tucker Carlson no ty era look-alikes or
Ann Coulter minis and I just spent
almost a whole night talking with him
just because I'm how do you this was
long before all right long before this
show really existed as it does now or
Milo or any of the rifle you know what
sort of become I don't want to say more
hip but acceptable to be conservative
now popular I want to see how do you get
in here because I was always not one out
yeah and then the next year he brought
me back to that school and I didn't even
recognize me at a polo and he had cut
his hair as a greasy greasy finish going
again it's off-putting but not to me
that's fine
those guys those guys gonna filter pubes
- Wow I like metal I like that kind of
stuff it brings yeah why do i though it
was funny because and not funny the
situation that happened but funny how
things transpired after that because
that person that was a mutual friend who
I did not like though you have said I
liked in my wife that I liked great girl
yeah great be very clear but she
actually kind of predict this is one of
the rare prophecies that anyone has ever
I just immediately discount them a cheap
told me that effectively she's like I
just I think that you're gonna be doing
what we're doing right now really yeah
because she wasn't someone who went out
she said like that I really do think
that what you're doing is important as I
started this direction she said I think
you need to stay in this direction she's
really also calls she called Hillary as
your wife very early on that's true to
me we were good friends I so the the
whole story is that I was I was in
ministry school with this group of
people and there was there was people
that were way older than me there was
people that were way younger but I
served use it as well is it of course I
created a class called the Christians
response to Islamic thought speakers
together from different places then I
taught specifically on Islamic
eschatology as it relates to Christian
eschatology so it was really interesting
I had a lot of background in that Julie
you eight Muslim snails not as car
that's a joke I would make better than
that Steve right now but anyway this
this person ended up getting in a car in
a pretty serious car accident and so you
and I actually spearheaded like raising
funds with different people that we knew
and friends of hers to buy her a laptop
because she was gonna be at home for
months recovering and you know this is
when I had very little neither one of us
had any money at that point everyone you
hired me for like twenty thousand
dollars a year yes to do fear for your
your wine less I do I think
yeah exactly that was way back someday I
needed the money
yeah well you you had me as I was not
Muhammad's wife let's try I mean that's
how broke you were you couldn't afford
any talent at all I'm like Stephen I
don't know how to do any of this and
you're like well just say this like a
woman and we'll go to the public park
and shoot this anyway she gets into an
accident and then you and I kind of came
together to help but you know put a
campaign together buy a laptop we ended
up buying a laptop for this person yeah
she ended up you know being kind of
heavily involved with your family and so
I think that's one of the ways that our
friendship connected a little bit more
yeah because he gave us more
opportunities to hang out and then we
just kind of develop from there and then
ended up being in your your wedding and
that was the first time I saw or didn't
see Stephen naked do you remember that
at the house so you remember in mind
this is true we were in a house I was an
accident my family had a house was a big
old house in northern Michigan yeah and
we ended up somehow in the dinosaur room
but it was monkeys those monkeys yeah
well it looked like it kinda looks like
Jurassic era yeah prehistoric plants of
this wallpaper monkeys and we were in
bunk beds and these were not he's
definitely were not been dropped tested
for adults too so every time that was in
the bottom bunk the bed would bow like a
hammock
yeah just had a nightmare of the second
bunk collapsing I had on that mare that
I made it collapse on you like right
before your wedding and of like god I
mean a kid so here's what happened we
you went to the bathroom which was just
right outside and you had the light on
I'm known for that and yeah so you had
the light on and I was I got up because
I was waiting I was like I gotta really
gotta go so as soon as you were coming
out I would but I saw in the light I
couldn't see you and so when you came
out you saw me me like ah and you were
naked I'm like oh hey I didn't find that
you were naked til the next day you were
like I was naked I was like I had no
idea I couldn't see I still feel like
you don't really see me don't a lot of
times that's why I hate James Cameron up
to this report but like at the premier
going through the red carpet and then he
goes new Macungie but whatever something
serious in him on it and she goes what
that means and what's the name of that
Navi that means in Navi
I see you oh shoot is he still working
on avatar - is that still a thing yeah
he's he's trying to work on all of them
at the same time yeah which is fatal in
decades yeah he'll probably die before
that ever happens that was that was
really that was kind of funny that that
week I think is where our friendship
really kind of grew a lot because we've
spent a ton of time around each other
well I think it's also why we good
examples comparing that to your wedding
yeah how we sort of counterbalance each
other as friends because you remember
how nervous I was
yes I was like boy came in really handy
yes during that entire summer of the
Dark Knight Rises doing but I like I
would say this when people are like oh
if you know it's the right person you'll
just know and it'll feel right nothing
for me ever feels right
yeah ever before I do a show every
single show I want to leave and quit and
I feel like I'm we're going to screw it
up therefore every major decision I feel
all this pressure I always get super
it's just been something that I've had
to struggle with and kind of balance
that's why I need people who I trust in
my circle to say this objectively is the
right decision to make right worse than
you exactly I didn't know what to expect
I thought maybe that would be a little
bit more nervous not not about the
person for sure but just the enormity of
the event that I was like oh well were
you all nervous
okay I wasn't at all yeah no no just no
just you meant sorry I should also
mention that my wife was horribly
abusive physically Oh so I that seems
ready so much have cold feet yeah
she threatened for bodily harm yeah if
you missed anything up no it's just
listen different different folks worry
about saying we do have another question
oh all right all right here we go happy
Ash Wednesday boys that's the best I can
do because I'm a Mormon
I just want to say I appreciate this
show so much and like seriously thanks
for the entertainment and enlightenment
Crowder you're my hero
ride around right alongside the cheeto
dust legend himself I have a
multi-layered question that I want to
ask you guys can decide how deep you
want to die but headlining question
are you guys car enthusiasts and then
what was all yours
first vehicle and to top it off who out
of you
quarterblack has the most speeding
tickets
alright thanks guys appreciate it
Merry Christmas or something why why
should that multi-layered question yeah
just like your undergarments mister
moment by the way Johnny boy for out
there see if we can push I have a call
five minutes late yeah I am NOT a car
enthusiast right I know more about
motorcycles and I do about cars because
that was sort of my luxury vehicle until
I moved from Michigan in Texas and I
wouldn't go I wouldn't be caught dead in
a freeway because I'd be caught dead
yeah on a motorcycle I just like a car
that gets me from point A to point B but
we did get a company car no we have a
used expedition because we needed
something that was safe stable big right
now outlet - so you can plug in your lap
luckily and we also had the secret
shitty news van before that but that's
for sale by the okay yeah but I don't
know I actually do but after I got into
a car crash my wife was like you can
only be in the safest vehicle that we
can find oh it's a little rickety first
vehicle was an eighty two dots and
eighty two dots and 200sx
nice with hey do you remember $652 yes
because I had an IOU for the fifty to
the tomb yeah this is from a guy named
Sun civet in Inglewood he was Cambodian
and to his credit he trusted me for the
50 yeah for a while I mean I lived that
out for a long time I slept in it for a
little while right I don't want to say
I'm not like Jul where I was living out
of a car yeah I knew it was for a season
I didn't have any place to land at this
point I think I've talked about the
Union yeah he had to pay and thankthank
you again Jordan for covering those for
me before I gone to the set of
frederique where my character's name was
Jace but am i loving called drunk guy
number two yeah didn't quite have it was
anticipated yeah
motivation but who has a Datsun 200
without a driver's side window Trash
Pack works just as well because it was a
it was a California anomaly never rained
rain and I actually I wish I had that
car now was very unsafe because I didn't
replace the tires and I was down to like
the metal wire yeah the wires grab ahold
of the concrete as you go along 38 miles
to the gallon
this is in California when gas was very
expense it was EF $5 it is so not a car
enthusiast but I like cars that for me
like a car is like an iPhone in the
sense that I want a car that I enjoy I'm
comfortable in is safe
it gets me from point A to point B if I
could have any car that kind of fits
those parameters would probably be like
a Porsche Cayenne used just because
practical but also really fast yeah
and in riding a motorcycle you realize
that that speed is actually safety
having that power and get out of the way
yeah because you don't want to be in a
blind spot in a motorcycle so definitely
Tommy pretty aggressive I don't have any
speeding tickets I have none no you and
you have sped yeah refused ly yeah proof
that the wayward night
it's a white privilege and I've never
remember the other day when I was
looking at knock on wood was on John's
iPhone case but not in a long long time
I haven't gotten a speeding Ted you
getting on any in your life to - okay
all right so a long time ago but yeah
and and I didn't pay the first one so
the second time was actually the day of
the Union incident in Lansing Michigan
my license was suspended because I
didn't pay the first one and I forgot
about it because it was a ticket that I
got in my wife's car owned at that point
I was visiting was a city where I didn't
live in a car that wasn't mine and they
posted it to an address right never been
nor had my wife I don't know what
nowhere that's weird so I went in and
they cleared it nice yeah that works out
for a while it was a felon what I've
known that about you for a long time
your first car so I I think if so my
first car was a I don't remember the
year it was sometime like an eighties
model Chevy Blazer
with two hundred and forty-nine thousand
miles on it when I purchased it for
$1,000 even I was very very you know
poor in my family my mom and dad scraped
together somebody buy me a car
so I was eternally grateful to have a
car I didn't care that the
passenger-side window didn't work I was
made it was like the ceiling was like
that thing falling down and you're kind
of like having and weaving around it and
pushing it I lost
Joe Frazier when yeah exactly
and so if I could if I could learn one
thing a little bit more than I did
growing up it would be cars like I just
didn't know anything about cars at all
my dad was a mechanic when he grew up he
started working when he's like 14 13
years old he was just an old soul early
yeah I had a job down at a local you
know mechanic shop and and then I right
after college we formed a group and
bought a racetrack like 3/8 mile
nascar-sanctioned racetrack that I was
part owner of up in Ohio and I was a
Lorain County Speedway and it was it was
now that went down a rabbit trail and we
only have four Matt well but here's the
thing
for cars I started learning there a ton
about cars inside to work on cars and
had to make the rules for all the rest
you're very good driver and I will say
I'm actually pretty I'm an aggressive
driver yeah pretty good driver I am a
waited undid the racing thing I am way
more aggressive I'm super comfortable
being close you talk to me the outside
inside out yeah which I'm gonna learn
officially until I took my motorcycle
class later this is what Jill was
talking about and yeah you driving tip
yeah for sure
audio wait was your first car my first
car was a a No 7 Jeep Liberty Liberty
next time you tell the story
I got a gremlin yours 1968 Ford Mustang
that was your first car Wow scarred it
was it was a rust bucket like yeah I
could see the ground under me was behind
definitely a fixer-upper and my dad got
it for me so we could fix it and we fix
it up halfway and then I broke down and
I was like I can't do this anymore
that's right well we did we also gave
you I think we charge you like a hundred
dollars cuz I was one like yeah car just
so we could change the title and you
have to pay something the van yeah which
air conditioning didn't work I never
heard the end of that not from you
but it was great part the interior of
that car was at what 98 Caravan yeah it
was like stepping into 1998 the interior
was brand-new I love that van and it was
temporary but he had it you know he's a
whole troop yeah families like you know
what we don't need this [ __ ] we
appreciate it
the windows work so there's your a/c
yeah I used to you know I used to my
heart might see Garrett pull it was like
oh he's using it he's actually enjoying
it because listen it's not it's not cool
it's not a chick magnet but it was a car
that were practical and um I've actually
was like minivans
he's a quarter black man that's all we
could give him yeah I actually wanted to
get a minivan except they're so
expensive used because keep their resale
yeah but I would gladly drive a minivan
over a over an SUV but I just I prefer
SUVs big time yeah me too I like them a
lot better I like just a sitting a
little bit higher and they don't make me
look as old as I really yeah I don't
like the curves of a van I don't mind
him I see I'm very practical with that
stuff like I just find them very
comfortable I will say though the the
the expedition that we have I don't know
if we need to bleep that because I'm
people might be looking for it but
there's so many there's a lot of them it
is so comfortable to be in that in that
car it's big I mean you know we got it
we got an older car 38,000 miles and it
is realize I would I don't understand
why anyone would buy a new car so mister
cigar las' Mormon I appreciate the
question we can expand on that maybe a
little bit more another another time
when we talk about cars I do like the
idea of cars
I just don't know a whole lot of yes
right well I want to hear Garrett's
ticket stories we can do that later yeah
extensive Gary Wayne right you win yes
least fun I want to make sure we at
least answer that question I've had I've
had one speeding tell me exercise every
black I've ever known has had a lot of
speeding tickets that tracks that
conversation so when I was in Los
Angeles before I bought the van I was
kicked out of someone's house who was
actually contact from the church where I
went over and then I argued with him
about Obama
but then he was talking about being
pulled over because it was black now
that you just told me that you had like
eight speeding tickets in the last so
it's not real time but and then I went
to the church that was primarily black
and all of them had a tennis but he was
he was just reading Jinga monasteries
you know
listen I'm not asking you if it is but I
they all I lived with three different
black families at different yes I went
to two different light churches one in
actually three because technically it
was two different forms of the
congregation one in Jamaica Hills start
one in forced Hills wanted to make it
Queens and then one in Los Angeles they
all got up later than most white people
that I know and seemed to have a lot of
speeding tickets those are the things I
know DJ's running late and dwb know
we're just aggressive all right okay
well that we really appreciate it this
has been the Ash Wednesday and you know
tomorrow is gonna be the live show don't
miss it at 8 p.m. Eastern
we love you keep wearing the holy
underwear
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]